[Musique]
la bellisé ville d'arr d'histoire 50 ans
niveline accueille chaque année de
nombreux visiteurs ce qui est bénéfique
pour l'économie locale et pour l'image
du territoire doté rappelons-le de
nombreux atouts culturels naturels ou
architecturaux des atouts que la
communauté d'agglomération cherche à
valoriser afin de développer encore le
tourisme et donc le développement voilà
c'est tout de suite dansen bien vivre
[Musique]
oh avec par exemple en 2012 177000
visiteurs à France Miniature qui est la
trè destination touristique des Yveline
ou encore
17390 au Musée national de Port Royal
des champ 5 ans en Yveline et Ben et
bien un territoire doté d'atout
touristiques tout de suite le point à
l'Office de Tourisme de Saint-Quentin
qui accueille 17622 visiteurs en 2012 ce
qui fait de lui le 3ème office le plus
fréquenté des Yvelines après Versailles
et Saint-Germain en lait bravo et
bonjour Valérie ferry c'est vrai qu'à
l'ombre de Versailles on est un petit
peu on fait office de de de
[Musique]
débutant mais on a d'autres atouts et on
va cultiver nos différences justement
pour permettre à tout le monde de
découvrir ce que ce que Saint-Quentin
peut offrir à tous ces visiteurs qui
viennent sur la région la première
destination mondiale he qui est Paris
île-de- France donc nous on fait partie
de ce de ce tout qui est la la première
destination mondiale les atouts dont
dispose le territoire ce sont des atouts
qui existent depuis bien longtemps même
avant 50 ans en yvline je pense
notamment au musée des granges de Port
Royal le musée du jancénisme qui
accueille chaque année en environ 20000
personnes des personnes qui sont
attirées par tout ce qui est le
rayonnement
intellectuel de de Versailles à cette
époque au temps de Louis XIV et donc là
on est sur un tourisme qu'on appelle le
tourisme de niche et puis aussi parce
qu'il y a un parc magnifique on a aussi
ce cet atout qui est France Miniature
qui draîne environ 180000 visiteurs par
an on a aussi notre labelle ville d'arrê
d'histoire et oui amis touriste
visiteurs et saintquentinois
Saint-Quentin va est bien labelliser
ville d'arrê d'histoire non c'est pas
vrai et ben si 50 ans N a été labellisée
ville d'arrê d'histoire en 2006 c'est la
première ville de la seconde moitié du
20e siècle et à forceorie la première
ville nouvelle à être labellisée Ville
d'art et
l'histoire c'est une reconnaissance en
fait pour le patrimoine du 2e siècle
d'abord qui a été quand même assez peu
distingué c'est le siècle qui a vu le
moins de monuments protégés par exemple
c'est aussi euh la reconnaissance d'un
patrimoine historique et c'est aussi
surtout euh la reconnaissance d'une
politique de valorisation de ce
patrimoine mais la belle ville d'arrêt
d'histoire ville les pays d'arrêt
d'histoire d'ailleurs c'est pas un
macaron euh qu'on colle sur les
documents de communication ça valorise
un projet de médiation euh fondé sur des
guides conférenciers sur une équipe qui
propose des actions aussi bien au public
scolaire qu'au grand public pour
vraiment faire découvrir ce
patrimoine
le premier axe de fort qui a été fait
autour du patrimoine contemporain pour
le label Ville d'Art et l'histoire c'est
les œuvres d'art publ c'est-à-dire qu'il
y a à peu près 80 uvres qui ont été
recensées sur toute l'agglomération de
50 anine c'est vraiment une
caractéristique forte de ce territoire
c'est un patrimoine à préserver et un
patrimoine à valoriser c'est-à-dire que
les gens perçoivent pas ça comme du
patrimoine ce sont des repères sur un
rond-point sur une une place là le truc
qui ressemble vaguement à quelque chose
mais on dit pas forcément œuvre d'art
mais il y a vraiment un vrai potentiel
et on commence à avoir du public
effectivement arrivver de l'extérieur
sur certains sites emblématiques comme
la commanderie des Templiers par exemple
les demandes augmentent je dirais que
les retombées de ce label c'est surtout
de changer le regard en fait des gens
qui découvrent le territoire sur le
territoire c'estàdire que ça institue
quand même quelque chose ah bon c'est
Villar ethistoire 50 an é vine mais
pourquoi du coup il y a une curiosité on
a un public qui commence à se fidéliser
sur les propositions de balade de
d'événements et cetera ah oui bah si
c'est reconnu vil d'Ar à l'histoire
c'est quand même que c'est il y a
quelque chose à voir il y a quelque
chose d'intéressant souvent les gens
sont très surpris mais dans le sens
positif ils sont très agréablement
surpris de ce qu'il découvreent et des
richesses insoupçonnées effectivement de
de ce territoire aussi bien ancienne
qu'on voyait plus que
contemporaine on a aussi toute la
politique qui a été menée depuis
plusieurs années déjà autour de
l'événementtiel sportif avec maintenant
ce fameux projet qui est enfin à
boutiquier le Vélodrome avec toutes les
compétitions à venir qui va forcément
drainer énormément de monde
50 ans en lin va pouvoir rayonner
au-delà de ses frontières grâce au
Vélodrome grâce à la REER Cup en 2018
donc ça passe aussi par les événements
comme le P de golf depuis des années et
ça passe aussi par la fameuse randonnée
cyclo touriste qui attire toujours plus
de monde à chaque édition le Paris
breest Paris qui devrait d'ailleurs
s'appeler le 50 ans nelin breest 50 ans
nielin puisque l'arrivée le départ se
sont ici et ben oui quand même enfin moi
je sais pas maison c'est une épreuve qui
a lieu sous l'égide de la Fédération
Française de cycl
tourisme c'est une épreuve qui a été
créée en 18911 et que la communauté
d'agglomération accueille depuis
1991 c'est la plus grande randonnée
effectivement en France c'est une
randonnée qui accueille à peu près 5000
participants en tout cas pour la
dernière édition en 2011 et c'est une
épreuve qui a lieu tous les 4 ans donc
la prochaine édition all en 2015 du 16
au 20 août chaque année il y a environ
50 nations qui sont représentées donc
c'est une très grosse épreuve
internationale et en gros sur le
territoire on accueille à peu près 10000
personnes c'est-à-dire les 5000
participants voir un peu plus plus tous
les accompagnateurs la difficulté pour
les organisateurs ça va être le nombre
de participants puisque c'est une
épreuve qui connaît un grand succès le
nombre de participants augmente chaque
année sauf qu'à un moment on attient
effectivement un certain seuil donc a
priori on resterait sur sur 5000
participants mais pas plus malgré
l'engouement de de l'épreuve un certain
nombre de de retombées on va dire en
terme de presse par rapport à
l'hôtellerie à la
restauration les les hôtels et
restaurants qui ont accueilli les
participants directement en tout cas les
les familles des participants à peu près
40 % d'entre eux on ont constaté une
augmentation de leur chiffre d'affaires
sur la période du parisbrest Paris et 80
% l'attribu principalement au
Paris-Brest Paris donc il y a comme
quand même un fort impact sur
l'agglomération sur la fréquentation des
hôtels et des
restaurants il y a aussi le tourisme
d'affaires ça c'est un élément
incontournable de 50 ans en yeline
puisque c'est environ 80 % de la
clientèle touristique entre guillemets
donc les personnes qui remplissent les
nuits d'hôtel et pourquoi une clientèle
touristique parce que 50 an neline est
la deuxème le deuxème pôle économique
après la défense grâce au Vélodrome
aussi on va pouvoir organiser des
congrès des séminaires ça va être une
autre dimension on n plus seulement dans
l'accueil de nuité pour les hommes
d'affaires on est aussi dans
l'organisation de congrès nous disposons
d'un parc hôtelier d'environ 1500
chambres ce qui représente à peu près 18
% de la capacité hôtelière sur
l'ensemble du département et puis nous
accueillons environ
360000 nuités par an donc ce ne sont pas
360000 visiteurs simplement voilà 360000
nuités ce qui représente 15 % de des
nués dans le
département
ce qu'il faut retenir sur le tourisme à
Saint-Quentin c'est que nous on fait
partie d'un tout c'est la région
Île-de-France c'est la première
destination mondiale et on va cultiver
nos différences grâce à tout ce que la
communauté d'agglomération et les
partenaires socio-économiques du
territoire mettent en uvre pour pouvoir
attirer de nouveaux touristes et voici
pour le tourisme et maintenant on
retrouve nos Actu
[Musique]
du attention la 3e édition de talent des
cités c'est très bientôt et vous avez
jusqu'au 31 mai pour vous inscrire le
principe de ce concours porté par BGE le
réseau national d'appui aux
entrepreneurs et la Caisse des Dépôts
soutenir la création d'entreprise dans
les quartiers prioritaires toutes vos
infos et les fiches d'inscription sur
ww.talentdescité.com pour mémoire les
élections municipales auront lieu les
dimanches 23 et 30 mars afin de
renouveler l'ensemble des conseils
municipaux pour la première fois les
citoyens pourront élire également sur un
même butin de vote leur conseiller
communaux qui siégeront donc à la
communauté d'agglomération et pour finir
sachez enfin que la Maison de l'Emploi
et de la Formation a réalisé un annuaire
intitulé les acteurs de la
sensibilisation au développement durable
dans le bâtiment et leurs actions sur le
territoire de Saint-Quentin en Yveline
un titre certes très long mais qui ont
dit aussi très long sur l'objectif de
clarté dans la dynamique
environnementale de la communauté d'aglo
la Nuur est accessible depuis le
www.ski.fr un dossier que vous pouvez
retrouver dans le petit Cantin du mois
de mars ainsi qu'un article sur le
fabuleux destin de rue du monde une
maison d'édition cquantinoise et le
programme complet de la semaine du
développement durable voilà à très
bientôt dans bien
[Musique]
vie